as a leader do you ever confide in
anyone or seek counsel from anyone or do
you just wrestle with issues within
yourself and try to figure things out on
your own another really good question
and I do both of course I try and figure
out things on my own but here's the
little secret is it a secret it's not
really a secret because I'm about to
tell everyone but it's something that I
wouldn't really talk about because just
something I do what NSYNC what we do
when I'm figuring things out on my own
at the same time I seek counsel no I
said seek counsel from the the trusted
teammates that I have or peers or
superiors or or subordinates that I
trust but when I counsel them when I
when I seek counsel when I get asked for
feedback a while I'm trying to figure
out things on my own I actually keep
those thoughts to myself in the
beginning right I let other people tell
me what their ideas are first I want to
hear what they come up with because if
and if somebody comes up with a good
plan we're going with it like if it's a
gray you know what that's pretty good
plan we'll go with that because as I've
said many times I prefer to use one of
my subordinates plans one of my
subordinates plan over mine I would
rather lose my subordinates plan rather
than mine as long as it's tactically
sound because then they they believe in
their plan right in if it's not
tactically sound yep I give him a little
nudge to make some Corrections and still
use their plan because I want them to
use their solutions in their plan so so
that way like I said they have ownership
of the plan and when they're coming up
with a plan
guess what's gonna happen they're gonna
get too close to it they're gonna do
what I talked about in that opening
story which is they're gonna they're
gonna be at low altitude they're gonna
be staring at it right in the face and
I'm gonna be allowed to remain detached
and remain at altitude so I have a
better perspective for the overall plan
than they do and that ends up making me
look like a tactical genius which is
awesome
so so I guess this is the secret this is
the trick or whatever don't talk so much
don't talk so much don't feel the need
don't feel the need is something you
have to resist as a leader as a person
that wants to be a leader yeah they
Foley system about people aspiring
leaders right if you're an aspiring
leader don't feel like you're the person
that has to always come up with the plan
or come up with a solution even when you
are the leader don't feel like you're
that guy in fact it's better to not do
that it's better just to to think and to
just listen to what people are saying
and watch their plans come out and get
shot down and get reformulated and be
improved and if you hadn't said anything
yet guess what the longer you don't say
anything the more people are gonna
listen when you actually open your mouth
so just kind of keep your mouth shut
now here's this is a little bit
different cuz we're talking about like a
plan right a strategy or something what
if it's something political within your
team you know what I mean then what do
you do what I do is the same thing like
I will think I will listen I will
discuss things with people and gather
intelligence from them I'll ask them
some probing questions but I'm not gonna
divulge what my position is because
number one that will influence them it
will make them react and I don't want to
influence anyone or make them react
until I'm gonna be able to influence
them and get them to react and act the
way that I want them that's gonna
benefit the team so I'm gonna ask some
some questions
hey what did you think about what he
thinks going on with Jimmy is he he
seems to be act is he okay mm-hmm I'll
ask you I'll ask him I'll ask Mike I'll
ask Bill
I'll ask Jennifer wolf I'll find out
what's going on something wrong Jennifer
and bill they say something a little bit
different okay see I'm gonna gather the
political perspectives and listen I'm
gonna let things unfold I'm going to
observe and relax and detach and listen
and
and calculate that's what I do and
dichotomy if something needs to happen
and I have to be decisive I'm gonna make
a decision we're gonna go with it
mmm I'm gonna promise put it out there
so oddly enough as a leader don't talk
so much I know that seems crazy hmm
the more you talk the less people listen
what about in like everyday stuff I
guess maybe this wouldn't really apply
to as a leader but maybe like as a
person you know like like you uh you
know come fight you know like I'll have
a frock um in and I'll be like hey let
me get your advice whatever about
something that obviously didn't feel
yeah like appropriate to like just ask
all my friends kind of thing you know
like do you ever do that no you just
mainly think about it usually well what
I would do is you know I like I do it I
what I just said I would do I'd be like
hey man what's going on with this you
know now I guess if you were see you
when you come and ask me something
you're asking me something you always
ask me about something I'm not a part of
in any way yeah so it's different so
yeah if it's like that if it's something
I'm completely if something if there's
someone that's completely outside this
situation yeah I'll say hey this is
what's going on you know this what's
going on here we had this happen I got
this situation and just yeah for sure
I'll do that yes so that is that is good
but but if it's within the team then I
generally just won't come out and ask
like hey what do you know I want to
change this instead I'll be like hey
what do you what would you change about
you know what I mean yeah yeah ask them
what they think first yes you might have
to make some adjustments I come in as
like echo we're changing the way we
record this thing now here's what's
happening yeah and you're like okay and
you're listening and the first thing you
say to me is like oh that doesn't make
any sense
yeah now I feel now I'm an idiot
especially when you say well here's the
here's why it won't work Jocko loan you
lay out three things instead if I was
like hey man what would you think about
this issue that were having
what solutions do you think we could do
to solve that mm-hmm and all of a sudden
I get to listen to your ideas and by the
way when you come up with one of those
ideas and one of them sounds pretty good
to me guess what we're doing that one
now who's got ownership of that idea
yeah now who's all fired up to implement
it you do yeah and I didn't waste any
leadership in fact I gained leadership
capital because now you're like man
chuckles are you trust me dude
yeah pretty cool he's letting me run
this yeah yeah and as speaking from
person who doesn't necessary well it
doesn't seem like I necessarily get that
big of a payoff to have that out to like
I'm running this you know like in there
I don't know for whatever reason didn't
I I never felt like that was a big thing
to me to be the guy running it but I
don't know maybe it is maybe my
subconscious because I know that you do
that to me and I'm that's why it's
actually kind of funny because you don't
do it in beat with big things
necessarily you know maybe maybe you
will whatever but most the time it's
just some little teeth small thing and
like oh yeah you know just totally
falling not falling for it I guess it's
a good tactic but now that how you just
fully just illustrate it I mean why
should know this I do know this really
that you do that sort of thing it's not
a bad thing no I'm not smelling you over
oh it's absolutely perfect yeah I'm not
I'm actually it's actually beneficial to
you yeah you're actually actually are
running things yeah no and if I come and
say hey we're you know hey what do you
think kind of table we should get for
them podcaster what you know you know
what do you think what you think would
be the best lighting system you know
like I know what I think that's - see
that's the thing I don't really divulge
isn't you know I know what I think yeah
and you know what though which year I
know I understand but by the way the
table thing that I tried with on that
one didn't work now I feel a little bit
actually I failed because I should have
put much clearer parameters around the
table scenario yeah for those either
don't know what we're talking about
which is no one in the world except for
us - if we had we got a different table
for our for our recording studio which
is right at this moment being expanded
and but we're still in the small
recording studio
I figure why we needed a new table
because the other one was too big no we
were adding another camera
okay we're adding another camera and
possible guests so so si hey man you
know grab a table and the one the table
that I had gotten in the past let's face
it it was it was legit echo goes and
gets a table I don't know if that thing
costs 48 dollars but it wasn't worth it
was Wiggly and small and weak and
anyways that's an example where I didn't
do a good job and it's also an example
of occasionally your your vision isn't
aligned like my vision normally you and
I have very lined vision about something
you know swell when it comes to the
technical nature of what the podcast the
table we weren't on I wanted to bought
that table ever well I would have bought
that table for like a like a prop to be
used in a one scene that but well okay
so I'll admit I think I don't know if I
told you this but I'll admit that the
thing is you probably when you got your
table you probably went somewhere and
was like yeah that's the table you felt
it and was like yeah I can imagine in
your eyeball and I actually ordered it
online but okay I I'd say I have more
even though I know you worked for a
moving company yes nonetheless I think I
have more I'm more worldly when it comes
to Friday hey that's a cool table and
that that's the dimension yeah yeah when
it came in it's the old story you know
this look oh it looked good in the
picture you know kind of thing that when
it shows up is like yeah yeah in the
picture and it's only $39 she last the
other table we had was over a thousand
bucks yeah yeah it wasn't a thought it
wasn't question extra put a minimum
price yeah just to insure quality rice
to insure some kind of quality yeah no
anyway we'll do the point is yes
when you give somebody you let it be
their idea you keep your ideas to
yourself I'm not trying to be all
secretive but I'm not trying to be all
secretive so I look at it tell this
person because eventually my idea is if
it needs to come out it comes out
hopefully it doesn't come out hopefully
it never needs to come out because my
team comes up with a great plan and I
can just be quiet and they can go
execute it that's my goal
yeah occasionally they can't find a
solution and it's like hey man okay hey
guys and then maybe you know I'll do
I won't even divulge my whole idea I'll
say hey well what about you know what
about this what about an idea like this
oh yeah that's not bad man when you see
someone get a good idea they get so
happy yes it's so rewarding
yeah and so you want to give them that
gift and the way you do that is by let
them come up with our own ideas we're
just gonna make sure that they have oral
the experience with furniture
all right well there you go and I dig it
and cuz you know it's not really even
about that idea it's more about okay we
need a solution to this problem I don't
care what they you know there's a bunch
of potential solutions kind of thing and
yeah you might have one in your head but
you don't want to just start saying
we're just throwing it around as the one
yeah and also yes you're right also when
you divulge your idea guess what happens
to everyone else's ideas especially when
you're in a leadership position when
you're at a leadership position and you
divulge your idea everyone kind of
gravitates towards that idea as being
the best if you keep your idea to
yourself you let the true growth of
ideas develop things come out and people
are just trying to say like oh great
idea Jacque oh yeah even even if they're
not like a kiss-ass but you just you
just put an idea in their head and they
can't see it a different way yeah you
know and even if they do you put them in
a position where now they have to shut
down your idea not a big deal but it's
still an added element that you have to
like you got to kind of put them in as
far as that position goes yeah rather
than you you'll just kind of open up the
floor it's kind of like back in you know
who who has something to say kind of
kind of love the atmosphere you know and
we all can you know throw around ideas
and the best one comes up there you go
thanks brain oh man okay the better
table mixer I promise next question